Scott let's say that I don't have access
to your book and I don't have access to
a lot of other things so where would I
find what cells you would mention
earlier go to a red box see what titles
are on the front of the front on the
lower part yeah really
yeah or or that augment big studio
titles yeah but continue sorry Oh
interesting okay I did not know that
okay so then take take go to your local
red box peruse the titles that are out
there in the front it's been a while
since I've been to a red box so yeah is
that how it's set up where you have the
film's right there yeah I think look
it's it's a really it's a huge question
to say what should I write and I I do my
best to answer that in the easiest way
for new writers in my book and and I try
to break that down the best I can but I
mean it's it's a really big question and
the thing I certainly don't want to see
any screenwriters run into is just
feeling like they have to blindly guess
I try to answer that in the book but if
you don't have access to the book the
best advice I could give to a
screenwriter is yes you can go to a red
box machine you used to be blockbuster
but those all turned into cell phone
stores you can go to Red's box red box
machine look at the independent films on
they're so independent would be the the
family titles at the bottom look for the
live-action ones usually with a dog or
an animal on them and then also look at
the big studio films that are kind of
you know throughout the Machine you'll
see them in different spots whatever a
big studio film is look to the ones that
are like right next to that or get on
Netflix and find a big studio movie in
the lineup and then look at the
independent movie you've never heard of
that's next to it that's the independent
Hollywood zone that's where I work those
are the scripts that were in need of
that's that's where I think you're gonna
get your best indicator as to the genres
that work the genre themes you're gonna
see the number of cast members the all
that information and another source you
can do is if you have writing experience
if you have a couple of screenplays
you're confident and that you think are
interesting for Hollywood I would call
up development agents creative
executives
I would you can find their information
in several different sources LinkedIn or
any platform like that is a great way to
kind of kick start it but contact them
and basically say I'm interested in
writing the script what works and if
it's interesting to you could I write a
treatment and present it to you and then
write it for you you know you could do
that as it as a scenario and just go
direct to the source and write something
for them I mean I think that's actually
the big question a lot of newbie writers
have is how do you get from point A to
point B my whole reasoning for the book
was answering that question the best I
could
that's information I certainly didn't
have about the movie business when I
left film school nobody really tells you
how to bridge that gap of okay I I don't
know anybody how do I build a career out
of anything producers in Hollywood knows
they already know it self creative
executives in Hollywood they know what
cell they all have really great ideas
another way to do it is go try to talk
to them and say look I want to write
scripts I'm looking to connect with
somebody who knows what sells I'll write
whatever script you want me to write you
lead the way I mean there's a lot of
ways you could I guess really figure out
what's going to get you some attention
and that would lead to just a initial
five minute meeting I mean if someone
presented themselves professionally on
the phone and and and seemed flexible to
you would that actually then open the
door okay well we'll meet with you for
five minutes to see a spec script that
you have I mean it's worth it's
definitely worth a five-minute call I
think I think a true producer in
Hollywood somebody who's well-connected
a creative executive in Hollywood if
they're working for a company that you
know they're comfortable with but maybe
they're not having that opportunity to
work on the stuff that they want to but
they have all the connections you wish
you had that that's a great link and yes
if you went out to them and basically
approached them and said I have three
scripts of this genre
I would love to present them to you and
I'm not trying to get you to buy these
scripts if you're interested fantastic
but I'm not trying to get you to buy
these I just I want to work with
somebody and develop something from
scratch you're a creative executive you
know what sells you have contacts and
I'm sure you have story ideas that you
just don't have time to
put together let me be that you know
fixing your system I'll get you the
script you need and then we can go hit
the marketplace together and that goes
into faking confidence that's a scary
scenario to be in but if you if you are
able to approach that and basically
present that kind of conversation you
will actually see quite a few doors open
a lot of emails answered likability
versus raw talent what percentage do you
think gets people a deal talents
important I think likability is very
important I think persistence and the
ability to work hard are the most
important I think likability gets the
door open likability is a crucial factor
in terms of just being able to walk your
way into a scenario get people to listen
to you and take your ideas and your
talent seriously but that's part of its
that's the first part of the equation
it's the most important part of the
first step of the equation but once you
have that opportunity presented to you
you have to follow through with a lot of
hard work and talent you can if you're
not a hundred percent confident in your
own talent and no artist ever is the
best that's where faking confidence kind
of comes comes into play there's sort of
tricks and things you can do to sort of
push things more in your favor I
outlined that a bit in the book where I
list out all the things that readers
hate about spec scripts and it's
basically just an overview of everything
that is it is a turn-off to them it's an
indicator of a writer who just doesn't
get what the system needs and and why
it's important not to have any of those
elements and they range from everything
of too many characters in your script to
grammatical errors and things like that
very fixable things but if you if you
make sure to get rid of as many of those
you're just weighing more odds in your
favor of getting your script taken
seriously but ultimately the biggest
reason that a script is not seen to
fruition it's not it's not made what is
it usually the out of all the spec
scripts in Hollywood the reason it's not
made to fruition it's just people
writing the wrong thing so it's there's
so many my view is this it
like there's this stereotype in
Hollywood that there's there's every
every other waiter you meet is like has
a screenplay on the side every real
estate agents writing something on the
side and in truth like that that's
reality a lot of people come here with
big Hollywood dreams and want to write
that great screenplay and people just
kind of go ah well you know they're not
talented they're writing bad scripts
certainly there's a lot of bad scripts
but at the same time there's a lot of
very talented people who just aren't
writing the right things so they're not
writing the right things they're not
writing what Hollywood needs and they're
not presenting their work in the way
that it needs to be presented to get
doors to open so if they just shift a
few of those elements if they write what
Hollywood needs which are goldmine
genres as we outline in the book if they
if they present their ideas in a way
Hollywood needs to hear them which is
about pitching your story in a way that
is this is how my script helps your
company this is how my script answers
that that need in the Hollywood system
and then if you just kind of get
yourself out there at the same time like
that's how you really do it it's
building it's not it's not selling a
one-off script it's building a career
you